in an effort to avoid a potential
shutdown the House approved another
short-term measure last night to pay for
six more weeks funding Senate leaders
say they are close to a breakthrough on
a two-year budget deal Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill she's tracking those
negotiations Nancy good morning good
morning yeah what was surprising about
the president's shutdown comments was
that they came just as Senate leaders
were telling us that they were getting
close to an agreement in fact ever since
a bipartisan group helped to end the
last shutdown a couple of weeks ago
compromise is suddenly back in vogue
going back in again
the place to be on Capitol Hill these
days is the office of moderate Maine
Republican Susan Collins I think we've
made some real progress about two dozen
senators Democrats and Republicans meet
almost daily to try to hammer out a
middle-of-the-road immigration plan
we're back in the ball game now suddenly
it's cool to be bipartisan we're here
for the same reason we take the same
oath West Virginia Democrat Joe Manchin
passed around a pledge Tuesday urging
Senate colleagues not to run campaign
ads against one another the only way we
can change it to say we're not going to
participate anymore
to some it feels a little like the good
old days when being able to craft a
compromise was a point of honor how do
you get back to that place that's still
a national conversation whether the the
country wants that or not Oklahoma
Republican James Lankford and Delaware
Democrat Chris Coons lead a weekly
senators prayer meeting in this room on
the first floor of the Capitol I do
think it's given us a different kind of
relationship but there is kind of a
running joke that happens that it's much
harder to stab someone in the back after
you prayed for them in the morning when
they both say words matter can we call
that treason why not on Monday mr. Trump
called Democrats an American for not
applauding during parts of his State of
the Union address what does that do to
the atmosphere around here a lot of
people don't take it as a joke they take
it exceptionally serious the extent to
which it's troubling as it suggests that
he actually thinks in his mind that we
have an obligation
to stand up and cheer when he speaks
that might be true of the leader of
North Korea it's never been true of the
leader of the United States those two
senators will play a prominent role in
tomorrow morning's National Prayer
Breakfast but what we're still waiting
to see is whether all this fellowship
can actually lead to a path forward on
immigration so far we've seen a lot of
talk a lot of goodwill but so far Nora
no plan that could actually pass the
Senate next week fascinating Nancy thank
you so much